two of these four guys getting cheated
on right now they don't give a [ __ ]
how do you know these guys man
went to high school together yeah
they hung out with you
times are different man i grew up in the
90s that wasn't happening
a bunch of jock ass white dudes a little
persian guy
you on the wrestling team or something
what's going on
wrestling he's oh you're laughing at am
i right
i knew it i [ __ ] knew it you know i
knew there's a reason
[Applause]
this is your lady
okay and the rest you guys are single
huh
no
you have a girlfriend where is she
she's in miami
whose girlfriend your girlfriend is too
that's [ __ ] up they cheat on you
together they don't need to do that
you don't need to take a field trip to
cheat on your man you know what i mean
that's a foul
you can just cheat on him quietly like a
[ __ ] decent
cheater you know i mean
man what about you you got a girl
cheating on you too
hey well look if you feel bad being the
only single guy
not for long you know what i mean
a couple guys going to join you real
soon
you can't let your girl go to miami
alone dog come on just a girls trip to
miami that's the dick capital of america
call them see what's going on with these
girls
i'm serious yo call your girl
are you nervous right
[Laughter]
it's not cold in san diego his body just
freezes up he started doing this
holding himself
you want to call her i know you're not
feeling up to it no yeah yeah yeah who
is 1 30 she's probably sleeping yeah
she's
eastern time you know
it's 10 30 here but they're three hours
ahead so
you know she's probably sleeping
she probably is
not alone though i'll tell you this here
right now
[Laughter]
hey man it's okay we'll laugh at it you
know what i mean we'll get through this
together
if any you ladies want a newly single
guy
that's a good man right there dude he
let his girl go cheat on him and that
[ __ ]
that's a hero dog there's a lot of
pretty girls in san diego you could
cheat too you know what i mean this is
the female miami really if you're into
white girls this is your miami
you like diversity
go to la but if
and if you're specifically like latinas
20 minutes south
but if you like white women
your girls are both white
i knew your girl was white dog i knew it
i knew it bro i didn't have to i noticed
my focus on the wrestling team and he
got a white girl so i'm nice at racism
you act like that [ __ ] is wrong but what
if you're just good at it
one hour later jesus christ what's up
buddy
oh he just texted his girl what happened
[Applause]
facetime dad
let's see it what the [ __ ] did you just
text yo both their girls went to miami
together to cheat on them yeah for sure
yeah for sure for sure that's what i
said it's a great place that's what i
said
i thought he was gay the entire time
that's why she left he said he wasn't
he was like i'm not on any dating apps i
was like wait whatever you want to do
with your life that's fine you know
enjoy what do you what'd she say
yeah read the text hold up
she said did you get my snap check the
snap yo
where's she at snap
no she might just send it to somebody
else
she might have said that to somebody
else sorry dude
snapchat is the cheating app yo
yeah your friends are supportive god
[ __ ] somebody else tonight
ladies if you ever wanted to date a
minority but not really
guys thanks for watching the video if
you're a fan just hit subscribe stop
hating what are you waiting for that way
you'll get updated whenever i put up new
videos and we got a lot coming after
morning
[Music]
you